foreign
a familiar scene as a spring of strikes
turned into a summer of disruption
[Applause]
while some health workers have settled
Junior doctors in England are still in a
bitter war of words with the government
they say they're 35 pay request is an
opening offer and accuse the health
Secretary of canceling talks and
negotiating in bad faith if people
suspend the strikes then we can get them
on the table have talks at the moment
the junior doctors have walked away from
the talks we were in the middle of
discussions with them there were a range
of other factors that they have raised
with me in terms of annual leave that is
often canceled at short notice rotors
that have changed some of the well-being
issues with the longest doctor strikes
yet due this month the head of NHS
England Amanda Pritchard today warned
patients were paying the price for the
deadlocked dispute
but in this tussle between Medics and
ministers there may be a political cost
to Rishi sunak too cutting NHS waiting
lists is one of the prime minister's
five priorities but that could be
frustrated by a summer of doctors
strikes and the walkout by Hospital
Consultants due to start later this
month from Healthcare to schools those
in government say higher pay Rises that
are funded through borrowing risk making
the inflation problem worse but not
everyone agrees with that logic
with teachers in England due to walk out
later this month one Union boss
apologized to parents for the disruption
but said Pay Rises were needed to keep
staff in the profession there's no
evidence that public sector pay feeds
into inflation that's just become an
argument which the government is now
using in another attempt well that's
what did England say as well right well
just the government Bank of England
governor on half a million a year can
say teachers who earn on average less
than 40 000 pounds a year shouldn't get
pay rise I'm not going to take lessons
from him there's been no serious
negotiations labor has been reluctant to
set out what wage offers it would make
today the shadow education secretary
said ministers should publish the
independent advice they've received on
public sector pay I'm not going to come
on this program and commit to a figure I
wouldn't expect the Secretary of State
to do that either what I do expect the
Secretary of State to be doing we try
and find a way through the impasse
publishing the report committing to
talks getting serious about it there'll
also be disruption on the railways as an
overtime ban for drivers comes into
Force tomorrow and staff walk out
altogether later this month
disputes dragging on Plenty of problems
for the government few Simple Solutions
Rob pal Sky News in Westminster